i've been called a rock star botanist
because i do roping cliff climbing
hiking miles and miles and miles but
that was where the plants were
there is this huge extinction crisis
going on in hawaii and my caring about
the plants is really what is driving me
everything okay
[Music]
well my name is
steve perlman and i do work for the
plant extinction prevention program in
hawaii
our program focuses on
the plants that are extremely rare in
hawaii that have less than 50
individuals left in the wild
this is a crater of mount waialeale the
radius spot on earth and then in this
special spot there are several species
of plants that are only known from this
area and nowhere else
what we'll do is try to make seed
collections of these really rare species
that are going extinct this is the
cyania acerofolia they're extremely rare
i'm bagging the immature fruit right
here so that we can come back and get
seeds later
field botanists these days are really
having to push the limits to get to a
lot of our plants
the rocks are slippery
it's sometimes muddy and very steep
there are no trails people rarely come
back here
this is the lysomachia iniki nowhere
else in the world as this thing grow
about 40 plants or so are known and
that's it and we only can get it when it
washes down the cliffs in heavy rains
and storms
there is a wonderful feeling to go into
these remote areas and then successfully
locate plants
this plant is beautiful and unique
they've evolved in the hawaiian islands
you're out there with a plant that has
only one or two of the plants left in
the wild you're really really feeling
the emotion of what that's like you go
and visit those plants many times it's
often becomes like your family
it has been a really strenuous career
i'm turning 70 years old next month
and i still love the work that i do i
think i'd probably be bored just hanging
around the house and i don't like to
watch much tv or things like that so i
want to keep doing this work and not
retire
[Music]
[Music]
you